[Applause]
dorothy gurley
made headlines as being not only a
grandmother
to five but her 50 years of work that
continues today
as a nurse's aide at the same hospital
in long island so we wanted to celebrate
her amazing career on the front lines
and the dedication she has
to her family i mean how does she do it
in fact
i want to ask her dorothy welcome
hi jewel hello
i'm so excited to talk to you because i
have so many questions
okay i think your work ethic is so
admirable and fallible and just
inspirational and you've dedicated
decades of your life to your job and
like what
keeps you motivated since the day you
started you're just going so strong
what is it that is inside of you that
pushes you forward to be this prolific
and amazing
i love working with the patients i like
coming in
and i enjoy my job and i like what i'm
doing
yeah and i like the patients that need
help
you talk about the importance of having
a purpose in your life
and have you bestowed
this wisdom onto your children and
grandchildren
i always tell them to when you get at
work
come to work do your work mind your
business
do your work and go home what made you
be that kind of person
because when i come to work i do my job
i don't get into gospel and am i my
business
well i think a lot more a lot more
people could learn that lesson dorothy
am i right
yes um i hear that you have
no plans to retire how does your family
feel about that
they leave it up to me whatever i want
to do and i don't have any plans to
retire i love what i'm doing i love
coming to work
and i love at the hospital at work it's
like a family
i love that so much i noticed that you
look
absolutely radiant and beautiful i heard
that you said don't leave the house
without makeup on is that true because
you look gorgeous
yes i think your family and those around
you are so
inspired by you i'm getting inspired by
you i was so excited to talk to you
and speaking of talking to people i
spoke to your family and they had a
little message
for you take a look
thank you mom for everything you have
done
you have been amazing
you have worked hard all your life
and i admire you and look up to you love
you
enjoy your time i just want to say how
amazing you
are how beautiful how loving and
hard-working you are
and i strive to be like you someday hi
grandma we love you we miss you and we
appreciate everything you do for us
this is the time to take a break and
relax happy mother's day we love you and
we can't wait to see you
how does that make you feel may i ask oh
great
well dorothy we just want to celebrate
you
and your work ethic and i hear you like
to shop
yes so we're granting you a grandma's
time out and i know we're gonna have to
make you take it because you won't do it
for yourself so
our friends at nordstrom are gonna give
you a 5 000
gift card
and a virtual styling session with
one of their in-house stylists if you
would like and we just want you to
pamper
yourself and take this time we're gonna
throw in a lunch and a spa day
and all the things and we heard that you
love makeup and
i really took to heart that don't go out
of the house without makeup
so i'm going to put together a huge
goodie box
of all our flower beauty pres products
makeup hair
everything thank you thank you
thank you dorothy gurley thank you and
thank you for having me on your show
thank you for being the person that's
literally the purpose of why we're here
so right back at you thank you dorothy
gurley it's an
honor to hang out with you
[Music]